Kyle and Emily are Weathers hey guys how
are you
welcome welcome or y'all from him
city ah welcome to Nashville and you're
here to do a debt-free screen how fun
how much have you paid off 97 thousand
good for you man why did it go and how
long did that take three and a half
years and making what kind of range of
income during that time we started 80 in
the last year we made 160 Wow
boom look at you what do y'all do for a
living I'm a locomotive engineer uh-huh
drive trains and I'm an RN okay and
you're both working your butts off
yeah that's for that income I mean you
cuz you that those are great jobs 160
between the two that's ours
you've been talking you been pouring on
the cold no pun intended right exactly
yeah yeah man way to go dude you've been
working working
y'all got children first one she's
standing right over here how old is she
seven weeks tomorrow oh she looks tiny
yeah miss Dorothy's on baby duty she
hates baby duty by the way any chance
she gets all little babies so that's
awesome well congratulations y'all I've
been working your tails off what kind of
debt there was 30 and student loans and
then there was ten that I was my grandpa
and 57 was our house you paid off your
house yeah the house is done twos how
old are you - I'm 26 today actually yep
birthday today
and how old are you I'm 23 and your
house is paid for $160,000 here you're
just freakin weirdos pretty much you
gotta be dancing in the streets man yeah
we're pretty excited yeah you oughta be
what's this house worth Oh we put a lot
of work into that's a hundred or so yeah
look we actually want a small town I
mean houses don't sell for that much
there but it's a nice house
I'm it's a it's a dadgum paid-for house
of 23 and 26 years over the seven-week
oh yeah oh my goodness so tell me your
story what happened three and a half
years ago I mean you're only 19 and a
half years old when you start this right
yeah well I bought Total Money Makeover
in 2011 I started my job
ten and I knew I had a chance to make
some pretty good money and I just wanted
to have something to show for it yeah
man and she was in college at the time
mm-hmm and she was all for it she didn't
read the book she was like I got you
know college books to read how long
y'all been married 2013 so three years
you've been doing this since you got
married then yeah and you kind of start
a little bit before maybe okay yeah all
right very cool we was a was able to
cash flow her college and that's what
the first couple years working on it we
wasn't able to pay off that much but
last year was able really kicking gear
yeah knock it out so you just graduated
got your boards and got you're
officially an RN and going now yes I
graduated May of 15 I started work in
June of 15 and so I had what six months
of work under my belt to help pay the
rest of the stuff off so I think it was
what November we officially became deaf
we were scheduled to comes to you in
March but there was some we was high
risk with our pregnancy oh yeah so we
postponed and listen yeah J care baby
don't do dairy screaming well it will be
yeah don't you worry
that's awesome you guys how's it feel so
really good yeah I mean do people do
your friends just think you're nuts they
did yes now they think they're heroes I
don't think a lot of people know yet we
haven't really told a lot of people ya
know kind of worried about how they
might take it a little bit don't want to
come off bragging right ya know so proud
of what we've done yeah I think you
ought to break it like crazy you're 26
23 with paid for a house you're making
160 oh my god incredible absolutely
awesome well what do you tell people the
key is to getting out of that I would
say the budgets every month we got paid
on the 15th and 30th every time we got
paid we'd sit down looking you know we
got to pay this this month we're gonna
be able to pay off this much this
mountain just set your goals and we
actually beat what we was planning on we
figured to take it here after she
graduated everything off and was able
actually move everything like I said I
had a good good
last year made a lot of trips and and
then whenever she graduated and we
weren't paying for college she started
bringing in money that was there's a
whole turnaround there yeah that was a
big we knocked out 57 of it just last
year
yeah just boom like that very cool and
just watching your body language it
looks like you all were working really
well together yeah yeah we've been
together since high school you know I
mean this wasn't like a big strain one
of you trying to talk the other one into
it or something like that it's just like
oh yeah do this was dead yeah yep pretty
much
he said that's what we need to do I said
well you just tell me what I need to do
because like I said I was in school so
unfortunately didn't get to help out a
lot with financial part of it but we did
pretty good yeah you did you think over
half of it well yes after I graduated
but absolutely she doesn't give herself
enough credit now that's I think you
both get a lot of credit I'm very very
impressed what was the hardest part for
you all there's a lot of shiny toys out
there that you didn't by talking
yourself out of you know how many hours
a week have you been working I don't
really know the hours I make trips so
yeah about 36 hours you know do a round
trip you know I'd say probably average
three three round trips a week 100 hours
yeah what about what about you Emily I
work 3:12 since I'm a nurse so okay and
that's perfect and that's really good
with a baby too yes that works real good
cuz you got four days off right which
now you know now that we are debt-free
um I'm gonna go back part-time so I'm
gonna work to twelve so I can help you
know take care of baby and then I'm
actually going back to school in August
so what are you gonna get now I'm gonna
get my nurse practitioner
okay good for you thank you Wow yeah you
could you guys are gonna be so wealthy
it's gonna be ridiculous the amount of
people you're gonna be able to help and
the things you're gonna do change that
little baby's family tree you're you're
impressive impressive young couple
you're heroes are so honor to meet you
very cool all right it's Kyle and Emily
and what's a little bit's name again
lynly lynly don't scare her too much
she's right that was she's probably used
to debt free scream drug your place we
practice in the car a couple times all
right Kyle and Emily and lynly $97,000
paid off in three and a half years
100-hour weeks making 80 to 160 a year
cap it down let's hear a debt free
scream one two three branches Oh phone
out fun out fun Wow you understand where
they are with their work ethic and their
ability to work together and that income
and not even having a house payment you
know what most people making that kind
of money do I think about $400,000 house
and they want to work not much you know
it's incredible y'all I'm not I'm not a
proponent of war I workaholism that's
not what I'm talking about but work is
where money comes from and if you got a
mess you want clean up a mess you want
to change your life you want to move
some stuff around you work that's what
you do that's how that's how this thing
happens I hear man the harder I work the
luckier I get it was a Edison I believe
said that yeah it's a great quote I wish
I had said it but yeah I found it to be
true though the more doors open the
harder I work the more activity there is
a more the luckier I get
I've just been so lucky yo you wouldn't
believe how lucky I am and it most
people half my age follow me around they
collapse in a puddle as they couldn't
keep up but you're so lucky you know in
this bunch of
crap floating around this culture at
least tell you it's work that's what it
is and again works not all there is and
I'm not telling you to overwork and I'm
not telling you to abandon your family
and I tell you need that but this whiny
little kumbaya crap that's loose if I'd
call sure that's floating around and
then I mean a young couple like that
this guy's this guy's 26 years old 100
hour weeks baby boom the house is paid
for shut up oh you know he can do
anything he wants now the rest their
lives they can do anything they want you
work like no one else later you get to
work like no one else you live like no
one else later you get to live and give
like no one else
stink an impressive man don't tell me
the Millennials are all bad people I
just met two rockstars this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you